this is who I feel bad for because you
got the lbgt right
there's more every day right now but
I'll tell you when it happens
it all started with the ounce
and the elves are great no one has no
one has a problem
like some of the owls were like else and
everyone's like oh yeah Alice great you
guys are really cool with great dinner
guests
you know because they love knickknacking
but they always have interesting magnets
but they're good people you know General
there's some [ __ ] but in general and
then um the G's came in and the G's are
cool but they're male so they're a
little more aggressive but they're
they're a blast you know they're like
hey we're the G's males are like hey
jeans
what are you guys up to though I can now
we're facing some discrimination why
don't we team up you guys have the
Subarus we got like Raves
and uh we're pretty ripped and we're
fine we're hilarious
uh so let's do that you know we're a
little unpredictable we might have a
code problem but uh let's all team up in
the house you want to create at this
point everything's going great and then
the bees came in
the piece of people for a loop because
you never really know if you can go
camping with them but they're cool
like you know they're like anybody
they're like anybody they're like
anybody
[Applause]
and at that point everything's going
good and then everything changed with
the tease
the t's came in right and they're like
hey we're the t's and they're like hey
what's going on with you guys they're
like nothing matters anymore
I gotta figure out how to end this joke
all right so the t's come in
and uh they're like yeah we're being
discriminated again so everyone's like
oh we'll protect you teeth and they're
like yeah so let's all chop our [ __ ]
off
and everyone's like hey Whoa man
what's going on with you they're like
I'm gonna chill with my car
nothing matters a four-year-old could be
a tea never looks like dude can we kick
out the teeth they're like no he's
already brought the qdas in the eyes and
they're like you're gonna burn this
[ __ ] down and you go all the way back
to the ls and they're like we should
have just knitted sweaters
foreign
oh [ __ ] that might be a [ __ ] great
joke guys
you know you hear all those letters
together all the time lbgt lbgt and you
think it's just one big movement it's
not
all those letters are their own movement
they're just travel in the same car
together
so the jeans are just driving the car
of course next to the G's and the
passenger seat
is the elves
everybody likes the L's
except for the G's
I don't know what that's about I just
know the G's don't like them that much
the G's always say like little
subliminal digs on them it's unnecessary
[ __ ] it's not mean but you know what I
mean they'll just be like
oh he wouldn't wear that
the only thing that breaks the tension
between the L's and the G's
are the bees in the back seat
that's right there you go everybody
scream out when you hear your letter
[Applause]
if it's one thing that the L's and the
G's agree on is that the bees are
[ __ ] gross
they seem greedy to the L's and the G's
you know what I mean because it's
sitting in the back seat like yeah man
I'll [ __ ] anybody in this car what's
going on man
[Applause]
foreign
and sitting next to the bees all the way
in the back seat by themselves looking
out the window
that's the tease
everybody in the car respects the teas
but everyone also presents the tease
it's not the t's fault but everyone in
the car just feels like the t's are
making the trip take longer foreign
[ __ ] I don't know what you
what
can you pull over at the next exit I
need to use the restroom
there is not a restroom for you for four
states [ __ ] we just shut the [ __ ] up so
we can get where we're going
[Applause]
and just when that car can't get any
more intense the queues are hitchhiking
that they pick up on the road some white
dude and booty shorts is walking down
the freeway
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
that guy might be one of us
hey are you okay you need some help and
he come over there with them booty
shorts leaning on the window
hey what's going on fellas
lady
whatever pronoun makes you feel
comfortable in the back
yeah
I don't really know where I'm going
I don't know if I'm gay or I'm straight
or whatever
all I know for sure is that um get in
this car
and they make him get in and sitting
between the bees and the t's
I feel bad for tease
but they're so confusing
and it's not all my fault I feel like
they need to take some responsibility
for my jokes
because I didn't come up with this idea
on my own
this idea that a person can be born in
the wrong body
but they have to admit that's a [ __ ]
hilarious predicament
it's really [ __ ] funny
and if it happened to me you laugh
wouldn't you
that wouldn't be funny if it happened to
me I think it would be what if what if
it did what if I was what if I was
Chinese but but born in this [ __ ] body
that's not funny
thank you
and for the rest of my life I had to go
around making that face
stop making that face that's offensive
what
is how I feel inside
[Applause]